it's the last day of e3 press
conferences and Nintendo close it out in
style from Mario Odyssey to all of their
new games we're here to catch you up on
everything you might have missed let's
go after getting a look inside Reggie
feet the maze apartment we're going to
look at Xenoblade Chronicles to the
gameplay trailer set the scene with the
title characters agreeing to venture to
Elysium mildly cringy accents aside the
visuals look stunning so far and we got
a look at both the exploration and
combat modes it was also confirmed that
the game will be coming out in the
holiday season of this year my smash man
kirby then took the stage for upcoming
switch title Kirby the coop platforming
adventure has gorgeous colorful visuals
and intense smooching action it supports
up to four players and as you'd expect
features mechanics that include sucking
in enemies to acquire their powers
enemies can also be turned into allies
that can be controlled by either the CPU
or a real-life player there wasn't a
concrete release date for this one but
expected to arrive sometime in 2018 it
was confirmed that Game Freak is
developing a cool RPG Pokemon title for
Nintendo switch but no details were
revealed about it save for the fact that
it's unlikely to be out within the next
year
next up the good news is that metroid
prime 4 is in development for nintendo
switch but the bad news is we didn't get
to see any of it let's move on to what
we did see Yoshi is coming to switch
next year the platformer has been
expanded with three planes that you can
interact with in several different ways
Yoshi was shown shifting to pubs in the
back and foreground tossing eggs at
enemies and running around in 360
degrees to avoid a train unfortunately
again there's no concrete release date
for this one edgy Numa appeared in The
Lost Woods or a very convincing green
screen version to talk about the
upcoming breadth of the Wild DLC pack 1
the muster of trials the wave mode
trials of the sword was shown off with a
naked link battling boku blends we also
saw the new armor sets in action for the
first time including my Halloween
costume of choice tingle and master mode
Zelda's new harder difficulty it will be
available on June 30 this year we got a
name for the second DLC pack 2 the
champions ballad it will feature the
four hyrulean champions from breath of
the wild who are also getting their own
a me
if you need an excuse to swear loudly on
the train Nintendo also revealed that
rocket League is coming to Nintendo
switch with cross network play and
exclusive bubble cars it'll be out
holiday 2017 and also adds Mario and
Luigi caps for your rocket cars Nintendo
closed out their direct with the insane
looking Mario Odyssey Mario and his hat
are totally separable this time around
and it appears he can turn into all
sorts of things by throwing his hat at
it including but not limited to a frog
power lines a dinosaur a car other
humans a robot a Chain Chomp and Bullet
Bill the trailer also showcased a ton of
locations for the game which ranged from
cityscapes to ruins deserts haunted
mansions and wide open fields Odyssey
will be out on October 27 so not too
long to wait for that one that's
everything we saw from Nintendo do let
us know what you thought was exciting
and stick with us we've still got plenty
of news and stage demos to come on
GameSpot come in